this first one is important because as I
alluded to this morning I do say the
word of them anywhere um it's it's
actually wrong the textbook answer is
wrong I'm convinced it's wrong I'm going
to try and convince you of what I think
the real answer is and then hopefully
the icing of the cake will be i think i
have like a ninety percent idea of where
they got their answer from where are
these random numbers can be so here's
the setup they tell you in over a given
sort of winter period the probability of
a rainy day is i think they send 18 out
of 30 I think that's what I record okay
so you've got a arm a fracture you can
signify it's going to be via top bowl by
six that's three fifths right so we need
back because we've got rainy days the
question itself asks about dry days
that's the cop of it ok so the
Kahlenberg is going to be one takeaway
that probability is just too busy simple
ok then this is the question they pose
to you what is the probability that if
you pick up five days of random the
first two days that you pick will be dry
that's the question ok now what I'll do
first is I'm the way I'm going to
convince you is I'm going to show you
two different ways to solve this
question and the first one is very very
simple so you'd be tempted to thinking
especially when the answer give you a
different um gives you a different
number you're like what have I done
wrong have I missed something really
obvious ok sock up five days here right
now I want the first to specifically to
be dry right so on these two days
specifically this is the chance of
getting a dry day ok now the whole idea
ravine statistical is like there's no
replacement or anything like that each
day is identical so the chance resets
every single day so if I just took away
all these other days I just said this
day here right what's the probability of
that day being dry dry are you to our
five it's around five that's fine and
then you look at the next day
which is remember it's independent ray
it could it could be completely reset I
with the probably of this day being dry
it's still 2 / 5 right and that you said
well okay now I have three other days
that are left and they all are supposed
to be wet so I have all of the
probabilities okay now having considered
each of the days independently knowing
that they don't affect each other now I
arrange them in this particular way
there's only one way to arrange them
like that so all i need is all of these
happening simultaneously so what do i do
it all these fractures i'm gonna
multiply okay now when you go ahead and
you do this you should put it together
later I think that's point 4 squared
point 6 cubed you put them all together
from memory i think this is what you get
okay I think this is what you get okay
now this does not match with the answer
the text book so you can be forgiven for
thinking I have missed something
important the probability that they've
got is significantly smaller so you
think have I like countered or something
like that and I looked and I looked and
I was like I don't think I have so the
way that I would know whether I've
gotten this right or not I'm convincin
is is if i purchase another way will i
get the same answer ok now another
figure to be weird is that this is a
very simple way of pressure here it's in
the middle of an exercise about buy new
you prefer you like terms of doing fine
Daniel stuff could someone tell me why
is this a candidate for binomial
probability so they're all identical
events good now turning over every get
repeatedly and one more thing that they
were independent we've already said that
one what's the binomial advisor
we're invention multi-stage it's just
that there's I think you said eternity n
to talk that this or that this or that
this or that each event it's one of
these two probabilities and you just got
a set of a binary branches drawer okay
so how could I approach this question so
this is a proj noble one how could I
approach this question using binomial
okay so just to make sure I get this
right I'm actually going to draw this
out a little bit just so you're super
convince okay let's think about like the
probability the whole probability that
I've got here is going to be the
probability of the Renegades the
probability of the dry days this
combined to make one because they're
only going to be one of those and then
you do it five times because there are
five days yes now this is just one so
this represents every possible thing
that could happen okay no over KT no I'm
be counting every possibility and all
the probabilities weighted are all
included in the expansion yes ok so just
I'm not going to write the whole thing
out because there are six terms I'm to
bit tiresome but the first time is going
to be 5 choose doors I've written three
fifths first so this would be three
fifths to the power of fine and there's
really a two-fisted power 0 I'm not
going to write it ok but just pause for
a second what does this term in the
expansion mean when we're looking at
this situation what does it represent ok
so this is how many ways are there for
it to be wet every single day and the
answer is there's one way ride over wet
that's it ok there's no way that re
Rangers that looks different and then if
it's red it's raining every day well
you're just going to do this probability
five times make sense ok that's the
first term so this is already days or i
could say zero dry days you'll see why
I'm right back on the second then I look
at the next term in the expansion it's
going to be 5c one tell me what belongs
here what happens to the powers this one
decreases so three-fifths to the four
and then I get to bits right now again
what does this represent
this guy up here is how many ways can it
happen for them can i arrange forward
wet days and one dried a dry day when
you put these in you'll get a pro video
you can see I really need to do one more
turn right plus I'm going to get this is
the one I'm really interested in 5c two
three fifths cubed and two-fifths square
yes this is too dry days right plus da
da da da okay but it's important these
are all NCR coefficients at the front
right nco nco nco so the difference
between NCI and PR is what is the
difference between them it's order right
so for all of these guys order doesn't
matter that's because what you do in
finding an expansion we don't care if
it's a squared b cubed or a b cubed a
like the order i could just put them all
together so this is the number of ways
sorry the probability of getting too dry
days when you don't care where the days
are right there could be at the
beginning there could be at the end they
can be the middle separated whatever
okay so that means that I'm over counter
do you agree like I can kind of way too
many options here because a whole bunch
of them the dryer is won't be in the
spots that I want so then the question
becomes well how many of these have got
like how many ways are there to position
to dry days yeah because I only want one
of them right yeah I have 10 yet anyways
because I choose to as a result it's
already done 522 yeah so yeah there are
10 ways that you can get to dry days
with the other five yes lots but you
only want one particular case of that
yeah very good you're very kind of by
nine uh yeah you usually say by a fat
dog right so it's a factor of 10 so
here's another way to think about it
right here my dry days and here my rainy
days okay think back to me this NCR
notation
right if I were arranging five objects
in a loan there are five factorial ways
to arrange them but look I have
identical elements so I've over
countered by a factor of 2 factorial 3
factorial that is 5c too isn't it so
therefore my probability right is this
but I've over counted by this amount
it's minus e2 three-fifths cubed
two-fifths squared and you know I hope
you counted by a factor of x SI 2 right
cancel cancel does this look familiar ok
so you approach up this somewhat
overpowered unnecessarily a rigorous way
right and it's still the same thing
right you do five days you do it take
care of me order you get the days of the
ways those positions you want and that's
it I'm a hundred percent set this is the
answer okay now the only thing that's
left is well whenever here number come
from and I started I just was playing
with dinner I was trying to work out how
have they done this what I'm sort of
ninety percent because the number could
have come from anywhere well it could
have come from anywhere I think what
they've done is instead of thinking
about five days I think they've thought
about a week because the number i think
they give you is point zero one two for
something like that okay now again I was
just playing with the numbers and if you
have to dry days and then the remainder
is a week how many what days are left
rainy days five of them right so
three-fifths to power 5 which I think
you'll find is point zero one two four
four okay so seems suspicious that those
numbers are so close and that sort of
makes sense like there's a way you'd
phrase a question I'm going to pick out
a week at random and I mistakenly
thought it was seven days instead of my
favorite was weekdays I guess okay